what is going on everybody and welcome
to part
seven of the neural networks from
scratch tutorial series in the previous
video what we did was the
softmax activation function which is
what we apply to the output layer of a
classifier neural network and of course
the next step that everybody wants to do
is back propagation and optimization
but before we do back propagation and
optimization
what we need to have is some sort of
metric for
error how wrong is the model
uh that we're trying to train the first
kind of question or insight that you
might have is well let's use accuracy
that's what we care about why don't we
optimize for
accuracy so if we only cared about
the accuracy of a model we really would
just feed in the binary
true or false to an optimizer and
make the attempt to optimize the neural
network
that way now while that's i suppose
in theory possible the problem is we're
throwing away
a lot of of actually useful information
because our neural network doesn't
actually output
an actual classification instead what it
outputs is a probability
distribution so when we pass data into
our classifier neural network the output
is a distribution
a confidence score for each of the
classes
now while we do do a arg max to figure
out what is the predicted class
it should be fairly obvious that imagine
you've got the
it predicts the correct class but one in
one instance
it predicts with a 87 percent confidence
and in another instance maybe it
predicts with a 50.2 percent
confidence right that's a a there's a
difference there
and it would be very helpful if you were
the optimizer it would be very helpful
to you that's informative information if
you have to go in there
and make tweaks to weights and biases
one simple example of a loss function is
mean absolute error which is used with
regression so regression is just where
we're trying to
output a specific value rather than the
probability distribution that we're
trying to do
in our case but this should give you an
idea of why a loss function is a little
more useful
than simply doing accuracy
so with mean absolute error all you're
doing is just taking the difference
of you're taking the average of the
distances of various points of
prediction versus the
the target values and as you can see
we're just kind of showing some examples
here but as you're
more as you get closer to the correct
value the mean absolute error gets lower
and lower and lower
as you get further away it grows and
this is just a lot more informative than
being right or wrong
so again rather than doing regression
we're doing classification
with a soft max activation function on
the output layer
so our model is actually outputting a
probability distribution
and then from this distribution we also
know from the training data
what was the intended target value and
then from here we want to come up with
some sort of method
for determining how wrong is the model
now there are many ways that you could
theoretically go about doing this but in
general
the loss function of choice for
classification
uh at least classification that's using
softmax as the activation function on
the output layer
is categorical cross entropy the formula
for which is to take the negative
sum and basically what we're passing
through to do categorical cross
entropy is two probability distributions
so the formula for this is to take the
negative sum of the target
value multiplied by the log of the
predicted value
for each of the values in the
distribution so
this formula winds up simplifying quite
a bit to just being the negative log of
the target class's predicted value and
the reason for that is because of one
hot encoding so a couple of things
first off we will explain one hot coding
in just a moment and then also we'll
explain
logarithm if you don't know what a log
or logarithm is don't worry about it
and then also i'm sure some people are
wondering well why the heck are we using
that confusing formula
when there are lots of other you know
maybe ideas floating around in your head
as far as simpler ways to calculate loss
there
there are many ways that you can
calculate loss and in fact many more
challenging problems are going to be
likely solved by
some sort of custom loss function
entirely
it just so happens that in
classification this is one of the more
popular ones
one because it's successful it works and
then two it actually
becomes fairly convenient if you if you
can believe it
it becomes very convenient in the back
propagation and optimization steps so
more on that when we get there but that
is why so
so first off the uh the first thing i
want to explain is what is one hot
encoding
so the idea of one hot encoding is that
you'll have a vector that is
n classes long so however many classes
you have that's how long that vector is
and that vector is filled with zeros
except at the index of the target class
where you'll have a one
so imagine a scenario you've got three
classes that means you're gonna have a
vector that is three values
long if your label is zero at the zero
width index of your one hot vector you
would have a
one and then here are some examples of
various numbers of classes the intended
target label
and then the one hot vector that would
represent that
okay so what's all this about logs
generally speaking when someone mentions
log without specifying some specific
base number
they are referring to the natural log
which also can be referred to as
ln but you'll often just see log and
then programming just log and then you
know some sort of parameter being passed
when this is the case this is the
natural log and the natural log is
log base e or euler's number which
you've already seen
and is somewhat of a hint of why this is
a convenient thing for us to use
before we do back propagation so i've
heard that some people in certain
studies consider the natural log to be
base 10
but those people are wrong so for the
purpose of this series and programming
in general just assume that the
log of something means natural log and
that natural log is
base e
okay let's come down from the clouds for
a brief brief moment and
discuss what a log actually is what does
it do what's it calculating
so a logarithm in general now obviously
you can have different base values but a
logarithm in general
is solving for x
in the equation of e raised to the x
equals b so the input to your logarithm
is actually going to be this b value
so to see this in action let's uh i'm
going to follow the exact same example
from the book you can
code along if you'd like you don't have
to you can just watch and then
also you could use your own values and
just kind of tinker with it just to get
an idea for
actually what logarithm is doing so
first of all we're going to import
numpy as np that's what we're going to
use for
the actual log part and what we're going
to say
is we're going to say b equals 5.2 again
just using the same value from the book
and we're going to print np dot log
b so again what's what is this asking
it's asking euler's number
raised to what equals
5.2 and again euler's number uh is
something we've covered already
so we'll go ahead and print that and
what we get
is this 1.6486 and so on
a number now we can check this how can
we check this well we can quite
literally just do euler's number
times uh this and just make sure it's
either 5.2 or very very close
so for euler's number we're going to
import math
and then we'll just come down here and
let's just print
math.e raised to the power of that
this output so we can go ahead and run
that and sure enough what we get is very
close to 5.2 the issue is just a
floating point precision issue
so so yeah that's that's what a log
is and how it works so now that we have
an understanding of the core components
of the categorical cross-entropy
function let's revisit the formula
and how it would be applied to a single
sample with three classes where the
target label is a zero which would make
the one hot vector
one zero zero and this vector is the
distribution that we'd compare to the
prediction distribution
from the neural network so again to
calculate this categorical cross entropy
we start by taking the negative sum of
the target value times the log
of the predicted value for each of the
values
in the distributions
now one thing that should be becoming
more clear
is that we have a few of these being
zero times
something plus zero times something else
which winds up essentially doing nothing
and this is why because of the one-hot
vectors
when we calculate categorical
cross-entropy with one-hot vectors in
neural networks
it allows us to actually simplify things
quite a bit to just being the negative
log of the predicted target class
because even in that case
the value for the target distribution
was a one
so we don't even have to consider it
it's just it just becomes negative log
so you might wonder why don't we just
call this negative log
well first of all categorical cross just
sounds cooler but also we are actually
doing
categorical cross-entropy it just so
happens to be the case that it
simplifies down to being
negative log of the predicted target
class value
so now that we know that let's go ahead
and code
uh the the actual categorical cross
entropy solution on an example
so i will just clear this out and we're
going to be using the exact example from
the book which is on page 114.
and to start we are going to import math
we're going to be using math for
math.log in the previous example i used
numpy.log
but we're going to use math.log because
this is neural networks from scratch and
python
and numpy's kind of cheating so this is
how we get around that
so we'll use math in this example so
first we'll start with a softmax output
and for this we're going to use and
these are just made up values we're
going to say 0.7 0.1 and 0.2 so what is
this
so again these are just example values
that we're making up for the
time being and these are meant to be an
example of an
output that you might get from the
softmax activation function
from your output layer of your neural
network and what we want to do is
calculate the loss
on this so imagine you have an exam a
scenario where the
target class was zero
if the target class is zero what would
that make the one hot vector well that
would mean the
at index zero it is hot
otherwise it's of n class length which
is three so that would mean
our target output uh distribution
would be one zero zero
so i'm gonna get rid of this and now
what we wanna do
is actually calculate the loss so we're
gonna say loss is equal to a negative
and then we're going to sum together the
math dot log
of the predicted so this is going to be
soft max
output zero and we're doing it for each
of the indices so it's
uh the math log of uh softmax output
zero
times the target output
zero and then what we're going to do is
we're going to add each of these for
each index
so paste whoops actually i want to do
paste paste and then we will edit this
in
one two and then this would be index one
and two so uh let's remove that plus
and now we can go ahead and print out
the loss so in this case that is the
loss that we got and if you recall from
the animation
one thing to note is in in the animation
i think we actually flipped these two
things around it was actually target
output
times math.log but it doesn't it doesn't
actually matter
pemdas everybody so so anyway
but another thing you might remember is
the zeros so because we're
essentially multiplying these you know
we've got math.log and then what is
target output at index uh 1 well that's
a 0. what about this one
well that's also a 0. so so this value 0
is out
this value also zeros out what happens
here
we do the math log soft max our output
at zero which is 0.7
and then what happens here well it turns
out this is one so it's actually just
one times this so really this entire
formula becomes
the same as doing loss equals
negative math.log of
the softmax output
target class being 0. so let me
actually let's just print print loss
and we should see that we do indeed get
the same
exact number so uh that is
how that very complex looking formula
becomes as simple as
doing this now just for example uh
let us um i think what i'll do
is let's just take this and we will
print
print that and then rather than passing
this this kind of
this let's just type 0.7 so sure enough
we get the exact same value
and then let's say because this is the
target class let's say
instead the prediction was 0.5
so what you can see is and in fact uh
just to make it
abundantly clear to everybody let's do
this
now you can see that um so in this case
where the the confidence was higher
in the correct class loss is
lower and then where the confidence gets
lower in the correct class the the loss
this measurement of error gets higher
so that is our loss function of choice
here
that's how it works that's how it
simplifies
in the next video we're going to be
applying this to the
actual you know the code that we've
built up so far
but make sure you have a good grasp on
this because as we do that we're going
to be converting it to a class
we're going to be essentially converting
because it becomes this you know
negative log
of the output at the index of the target
class we're going to be abstracting that
away because we
also want to be doing that in batches so
as we add the logic to that if you don't
have a firm grasp of
what is intended to happen it can be
very confusing when we go to write that
code so make sure you have a good idea
of what's going on if you have
any questions comments concerns whatever
on
uh any of that feel free to leave them
below we also have discord server it's
discord dot gg
slash syntax you can come in there hang
out ask questions all that good stuff
otherwise that is it i don't know if i
mentioned it but the neural networks
from scratch book
is available it's on neural network or
nnfs.io
uh you can get the physical books a
hardcover softcover or the ebook so
check it out if you're interested
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you